Salut !
Aujourd'hui je suis avec...
Michael Hirsch !
-Bonjour !
Comment s'appelle ton spectacle, Michael ?
-"Pourquoi?"
Pourquoi je te pose la question ?
-Non, c'est le nom de spectacle.
Il s'appelle "Pourquoi".
Il faut savoir que Michael adore les mots.
Son spectacle est très drôle.
et il est intelligeant en même temps.
Oui on peut le dire...
-Oui !
Alors comme tu aimes les mots et la langue française,
je me suis dit qu'il serait sympa de se faire un Scrabble.
D'ailleurs, on prononce "scrable" ou "scrabeul" ?
-Francisons-le, et appelons ça un "scrable".
D'accord !
Alors, comme vous pouvez le voir
sur les chaque carte est inscrite une lettre.
C'est la version poche.
Tu connais ou pas Michael ?
-Non !
Eh bien en fait, moi non plus...
je n'ai pas lu les règles !
:D
Tu vois, tu as des lettres dessus
et tu dois penser à un mot qui commence par cette lettre.
-Ok !
Vas-y, pioches une carte.
C'est bon ?
-Ouais !
Maintenant tu dois penser à un mot qui commence par cette lettre.
-D'accord. Veux-tu que je montre ma carte à la caméra ?
Non, car on pourrait penser que je vois dans l'écran de retour
et les mecs en face ne me font pas de cadeau !
Michael, tu dois répondre par "oui" ou par "non" dans ta tête
Est-ce que c'est un objet ?
Quelque chose que je peux toucher ?
Quelque chose qui existe matériellement ?
...
:D
Non, je ne te répondrai pas...!
Pour moi oui.
C'est quelque chose que je peux saisir dans ma main ?
Que je peux attraper ?
Quelque chose qui remplirait toute ma main ?
ça déborde...
ça déborde bien !
D'accord...
Ok !
Imagine que l'objet se trouve devant toi
qu'il fasse cette taille là...
et que j'essaye de suivre ses lignes, ses contours.
Alors je vois pleins de courbes
et pleins d'arrondis.
J'aurai dû mettre ma GoPro, pour voir tes yeux qui font
(°_°)
:D
Je vois que c'est un objet qui peut, potentiellement, être utile.
ou pas...
son utilité est toute relative...
Je vais essayer de deviner la première lettre de cet objet
Pense très fort à la première lettre.
A-B-C-D-E-F-G-H-I-J-K-L-M-N-O-P-Q-R-S-T-U-V-W...
Q-R-S-T-U-V-W...
L-M-N-O-P-Q-R-S-T-U-V-W...
J'hésite entre S ou T...
S !
Je sens que tu penses à lettre "S" !
Allez, je tente mon coup.
Je vous dis franchement
j'hésite entre deux choses.
Je vous montre mes deux mots.
Michael, ne regarde pas l'écran.
En fait, j'hésite entre ses deux mots là.
Mais, je pense,
puisqu'il écoutait les traits de mon crayon,
qu'il m'a validé inconsciemment ce mot.
Donc pour moi, c'est celui-là !
Michael, peux tu nous dire à quel mot tu pensais exactement ?
-Un saxophone.
Un saxophone ?
-Oui.
En fait, j'ai hésité entre deux choses:
entre serpent et saxophone...
Et j'ai rayé "serpent" pour garder "saxophone" !
-Alala !
J'en fais bouger la caméra !
-Merci à toi Fabien et bravo.
Bravo à toi Michael, d'avoir joué le jeu dans ta tête.
Je regrette un peu, de ne pas avoir mis ma GoPro
Ca aurait pu être intéressant de voir tes yeux qui s'écarquillaient.
:D
En ce moment tu es en tournée ?
-Oui, en ce moment je suis à Grenoble et à la Basse cour
les deux prochaines semaines.
Cool !
Allez le voir à Grenoble, à la Basse cour et à Avignon.
Il sera au festival d'Avignon cet été
et je crois qu'avant Avignon, tu seras de retour sur Paris...
mais pour avoir vraiment cette info, il va falloir le suivre sur sa page Facebook
et vous serez au courant de toutes ses actualités !
Ca te dirais de participer aux "Hallucinations collectives" ?
-Pourquoi pas !
Cool !
Car dans les "Hallucinations Collectives", ce ne sont que des personnes atypiques
et je considère que tu fais quelque chose d'atypique
-Ce serait avec plaisir !
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne de Fabien
c'est génial !
Et ce n'est même pas moi qui l'ai dit !
On se retrouve demain 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog
Ciao !